[Music]  are you doing how do you process this  day how do you how do you process this  day we want you and I just want to say  that Judy it means so much to me  personally I saw her as you know at the  top of the town  I saw her perform at the Palladium that  at that time that she was living in  London and I just my god  because I adored her Hank your film was  just sensational it just breaks my heart  when I see it and I want you to win so  bad I honestly do and you've gotta go I  know tell me about the dress real quick  before you go anybody snagging anybody's  dresses what went into that choice how  did you make that choice comfortable  it's stunning good luck tonight  [Music]  you it's your night  [Applause]  [Music]